salut romain donc je te demande pas si
ça va qu'est ce qui se passe alors du
coup c'est toi si tu es en retard
je suis venu en courant une douleur
atroce là son côté sur le ventre d'un
point de côté exactement laisse moi je
pense que je vais faire ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on aime bien taquiner romain
surtout moi mais c'est vrai que quand on
a un point de côté et qui arrive comme
ça tout d'un coup surtout s'il est
violent on peut avoir l'impression qu'on
va décéder on avoir envie en tout cas
surtout si on est un peu drama commandes
d'ailleurs si vous avez fait du sport
dans de l'endurance au collège ou même
un petit peu plus tard si vous avez
essayé d'aller courir sans être vraiment
un grand athlète vous connaissez ça le
point de côté mais alors qu'est ce qui
se passe exactement dans notre corps
quand on a un point de côté et là comme
bien souvent quand on parle de ce genre
de truc je vais vous répéter la fameuse
phrase on laissait pas comme ça
h mais on a
et puis oui bah oui c'est toujours le
même truc hein on en a déjà parlé sans
être cynique les points de côté c'est
pas assez grave pour que les gens
achètent des médicaments contre ça donc
la personne va financer des recherches
bon mais alors qu'est ce qu'on sait on
sait qu en anglais par exemple un point
de côté on appelle ça une douleur
abdominale transitoire lié à l'exercice
c'est fou c'est en anglais ça sonne
toujours mille fois mieux même conseil
de l'anglais traduit en français c'est
quand même je t avais c'est dingue
voilà bref c'est une douleur qui
apparaît quand on fait un effort dans la
région de l'abdomen
ça veut dire le le ventre c'est pas
vraiment une région en l'occurrence la
douleur elle se situe sous les côtes
1 la sur le côté d'où le nom alors
plutôt à droite a priori mais il ya des
gens qui disent qu'ils en ont aussi à
gauche moi je vous ai jamais vraiment
fait attention à ça si vous vous avez
tendance à en faire
n'hésitez pas à revenir dire dans les
commentaires de quel côté c'est vraiment
bon jusqu ici tout le monde est à peu
près d'accord mais ensuite les avis
disent quoi et bat ensuite les avis
divergent
et oui parce qu'il ya plusieurs
suppositions sur l'origine réelle des
points de côté ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va aller des moins probable en
plus probable bon je vous passe
rapidement les théories selon lesquelles
ce serait par exemple une irritation de
la plèvre
c'est à dire la membrane qui entoure le
poumon à cause d'une mauvaise
respiration ou un problème de
fermentation de gaz à cause d'un repas
trop riches avant l'effort on estime
aussi que ça pourrait être une douleur
liée au foie vous l'histoire de la
douleur plutôt à droite parce que c'est
là qu'il est le foie juste sous les
côtes à droite là et ça lui ça faisait
longtemps mais ça pourrait aussi être
liée à la rate puisqu'elle est au même
niveau mais de l'autre côté à gauche
en gros vous faites un effort plutôt mal
géré et il ya un de ces deux organes qui
se gorgent de sang brutalement et qui
appuie sur un muscle était très
important et qui est juste à côté qui
s'appelle le diaphragme alors le
diaphragme donc c'est un muscle il est
juste là sous les poumons et c'est assez
logique qu'ils soient là parce que lui
son boulot c'est de se contracter de
créer
une dépression dans la cage thoracique
qui va permettre à l'air de rentrer dans
les clous
il ya déjà cette hypothèse dont on vient
de parler dans laquelle il est impliqué
mais il y en a d'autres aussi
vraisemblablement on est sur une
souffrance musculaire du fameux gaal je
vous refais le tableau vous pourrez et
vous courez pas très bien où en tout cas
vous respirez mal pendant que vous
courrez première hypothèse le diaphragme
et mal oxygénées disque est quand même
un comble pour un muscle respiratoires
comme quoi c'est vraiment les
cordonniers les plus mal chaussés bon
respiration inefficace vous avez
d'oxygénation du diaphragme souffrance
musculaire 12 ou alors tout simplement
votre respiration pendant l'effort elle
est anarchique le diaphragme
il est trop sollicité il comprend pas ce
qui lui arrive et comme c'est un muscle
mais qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils payent
sacrant le point côté ce serait une
crampe diaphragme voilà ça c'est
l'hypothèse la plus communément admise
c'est bien joli tout ça c'est très
chouette pour faire le malin dans les
soirées
mais une fois qu'on sait ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour faire passer un point de
côté quand on en arrive et bars ont fait
comme d'habitude quand on parle de
traitement soit on agit sur la cause
soit on agit sur le symptôme soit on
agit sur les deux bons déjà faut savoir
un truc si vous arrêtez de courir ça
s'arrête tout seul
en quelques minutes le temps que votre
respiration de vienne à peu près normale
et que tout ronds dans l'eau si ça passe
pas c'est que c'est pas un point de côté
et il faut voir un médecin
mais parfois on n'a pas envie de
s'arrêter de courir ou juste on peut pas
donc dans ces cas là qu'est ce qu'on
fait vous pouvez choisir d'agir sur le
symptôme c'est à dire sur la crampe soit
en appuyant dessus soit en vous penchant
légèrement du côté où ça fait mal avec
ce efficace mais le plus efficace c'est
quand même d'agir directement sur la
cause c'est à dire sur la respiration
l'idée c'est de calmer le jeu
et de reprendre une fréquence
respiratoire régulière est moins rapide
pour ça si vous pouvez ralentissez un
peu déjà à priori vous attend sur ta g
ensuite prenez des bonnes inspirations
expiré le plus longtemps possible
[Musique]
videz bien vos poumons à fond et puis
recommencer recommencer autant de fois
que mes ffr jusqu'à ce que ça passe mais
vu qu'on a dit qu'on faisait comme
d'habitude dont on parlait de traitement
et que maintenant vous le savez si vous
suivez mes vidéos le meilleur traitement
c'est le traitement préventif
exactement du coup le mieux c'est de
faire en sorte que ça n'arrive pas
évitez de partir courir sans avoir mangé
ou al'inverse éviter d'y aller après une
choucroute
par contre buvez de l'eau duwez en avant
et buvez ans pendant ça ça évite l'écran
échauffez vous pour faire monter les
fréquences cardiaques et respiratoires
progressivement et puis et tirez vous
pensez à gérer votre effort surtout si
vous n'êtes pas habitués ou si vous
n'avez pas fait de sport depuis un petit
moment
commencer doucement et augmenter la
cadence progressivement et surtout
concentrez vous sur votre respiration
c'est ça le plus important respirez
lentement profondément régulièrement et
tout ira bien évidemment si vous avez
vos petits trucs à vous qui marche bien
n'hésitez pas à partager tout ça dans
les commentaires quand on voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous prenez soin des
autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]